Yolanda Vega on the podcast would be a
great get we want to get Yolanda Vega on
this podcast we'd like to maybe she
could even do if your friends with her
if you're family with her we'd love to
get Yolanda on this and if you don't
know her since I'm a young person uh
this is the woman who draws the New York
State lottery numbers thanks to my
husband Miguel I am hey babe you're L
Vega oh my God we got it my children are
are Puerto Rican so so you know as
Puerto Ricans um we only there's only
two people who I want my daughters to be
either you veger or Fat Joe that's and
and and those are you are the two king
and queen Puerto New York Puerto Rican
so it's an honor final number is 62 wow
literally you just enacted s's fantasy
of yoland VGA pulling Lottery balls out
of his
lap